Hi boo!
Oh, bye boo!
Go-shin 'Sama!
Oh, jo-sama!
Hello!
Oh, yeah, call me director, call me director.
Come- No, no, no, no, no, no.
Say my name.
Say- Say-
Okay, director.
My boy boo to you.
And right back at you.
Right back at you.
screwed in my chair there we go nice so i recently got in a
chair and it has uh what are the things called armrests it
has armrests but i can't stop fiddling with them me and all
of you were amazing amories it wasn't her birthday it was
anniversary but yes Thank you.
I've been coughing a lot today.
I apologize if I cough a bunch.
It was so good.
It was so fun.
Callie invited us to to dance and sing with her a little
bit.
And it was it was so fun.
I was really honored.
I was a little starstruck too Because You know, like I was
like Oh my gosh I see her in my face You know, like Oh, whoa
Um Yeah Uh So It's funny that Minto was smaller than a chibi
Callie No No way I don't think so The deadbeats went nuts
when you all came on stage I'm so glad I'm so glad I um
Yeah, I was really excited to sing Discotech I didn't know
the other song Um, oh my gosh My brain is already like Empty
of what it was called How is it that her bar had apple juice
It's the best ever Every bar should have apple juice Um But
Dreamland Yes, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you
you yes I was really nervous singing that one I didn't think
it really sued in me so much but it was so fun it was really
cool to hear Vicky wrap the part so I was excited for that
so yeah if you haven't watched it yet the whole the whole
stream is so nice she also had Amelie and Iron Mouse as
guests as well and then and then I get so emotional with
Kiara and Ina and I was like oh my gosh these old models I
was so like oh and Kiwawa sounded so baby it was so she
sounded so cute I was like what is this mic that she's using
she sounds like a little baby yeah Walfi Walfi's models are
so cute the small ones I hope that guy's doing okay.
Don't forget about Amalie.
I said Amalie.
I said Amalie and Iron Mouse as guests.
But yeah, it was a great stream, and I'm really honored to
have been a part of it.
So, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You sound like a little baby.
You sound like a baby.
Got him.
This go-tech was great.
I'm glad you liked it.
Denso-sat-sat-sat-emotion expo last night was so amazing.
The atmosphere was electric.
I was...
Oh my gosh.
Yes, thank you.
Getting to experience it with all the density was the
highlight of the con for sure.
Thank you so much.
much thank you i i think oh my gosh i think like how to how
to yukai is becoming one of my favorite songs for us to sing
i feel like we sound so good singing it so i really like
singing that one good comeback rinto thanks i'm full of them
i'm full of them i do not sound like a little baby go go go
gaga there's a clip of you as the drunk girl at the bar i
didn't really So I like, you could tell that one, I don't
drink and two, I don't go out with friends because I just
downed the drink at Cali's bar.
I was just like, all right, bottoms up.
I never think, I was like, oh my gosh, wait, when people go
out to drink and stuff, they, they, you know, they, they
come by, they, they cheers together.
But it was apple juice.
It was apple juice.
So, I was like, oopsie.
It's beer o'clock.
Oh, oopsie.
But yeah, it was fun.
It was so fun.
And such a giga chad.
Yeah.
And then Moshi Expo was yesterday.
I had a bunch of meet and greets, and then the concert that
night, and that was a lot of fun.
Everybody did amazing.
Everybody sounded amazing.
Hello, Director Minto.
I hope both of you and Johnny are doing well.
Johnny is doing great, thank you.
He's asleep.
He's being a sleepy boy today.
You tend to down the whole drink.
That's more of a college technique.
But the apple juice replacement gives you no junker
advantage whatsoever.
Stop making this into us a lot.
Gets pulled over.
I've only had a couple of drinks, officer.
In 10 seconds.
Does Johnny believe he's being fed enough?
There's not a single cat ever that believes they're being
fed enough.
Every single cat ever will believe that they are starving
and will never taste another morsel in their mouth ever,
ever again.
Great job with the densest and fundraiser and Callie's
thing.
I was thinking of watching a Halloween cartoon after this.
Any recommendations?
Over the garden wall.
I had a lot of FOMO for Mochi.
FOMOchi, if you will.
No!
Well, hopefully it happens again next year, and hopefully we
get invited again.
I would love to go again.
My cat is not a real cat.
He is never starving.
you have you have not a cat that that's not a real cat
Johnny though he like in the mornings luckily it's around
when I'm already to wake up but he is one of those cats that
will walk on my face stand on my neck literally choking me
out he's like feed me women feed me but he is everywhere and
everything and all over I Ordered a Switch 2 after watching
the Zelda Nintendo Direct.
Clearly, I was not in control.
Is there an SCP that forces you to make bad financial
decisions?
Wait, did you get the Zelda?
Did you get the Zelda Switch 2?
Because honestly...
Oh, it's...
It's beautiful.
I almost...
I was like, you know what?
If I were to get a Switch 2...
I would have...
I would have tried for it.
I should have tried for it.
watching for two months, I'm fairly new to your channel, but
I love watching every stream I've been able to.
It's really early here, but welcome to watch you from
Australia!
Good morning, Sally!
Thank you for the super chat!
Welcome, welcome, welcome!
Yeah, welcome to the cafe!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you!
Appreciate it!
Great job this week, Minto.
Catching the clips of Johnny purring on Mike was so hard, or
me?
He sounds like a little devil.
He absolutely is.
Yeah, absolutely.
is.
Speaking of which, I just had to give the cats their 5 p.m.
meal.
I was 15 minutes late.
They will never forgive me.
Never.
Never, ever.
Dr. Pro, welcome back.
Thank you so much.
My auto feeder keeps my Lucy from killing me.
Well, Johnny's on a kind of strict diet, so I have to feed
him a special, specially, you know.
Hmm.
What?
I don't know if you've heard of this.
Sorry to take the topic.
Well, no, it's okay.
There was an experiment.
We're talking about cats.
They're all good.
There was an experiment where they took cats to different
time zones, but they could still tell their time.
Really?
I guess it's like a biological clock thing, right?
Maybe, like, they're just kind of like, I mean, if I eat
every day at 8 a.m., but I go to a different time zone yeah
the stomach clock right then i would still even say i go one
hour like where instead instead of like if it's 8 a.m 8 a.m
my time it's 9 a.m another time i would still feel hungry
then at 9 a.m probably right i think because that's my
normal time yeah the stomach clock transcends time exactly
exactly I'm starving, exist in all time zone.
Everybody hungry in their own time zone, right?
Hmm.
My cat definitely gets confused when daylight savings time
ends because she gets her food an hour later.
That is always rough.
It is always rough when that happens, right?
Yeah.
Oh, but yes, the body must feed regardless of...
That's why time is a social construct, everybody, right?
Maybe we should stop going off of time.
Like, like, one, two, three, and we should start going off
of stomach growls or something.
We all eat at the same time.
Does not matter your time zone.
Everybody eats at the same time, and then when you're hungry
is a terrible idea.
This is, it's food minus two now.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's good clock.
World peace achieve.
Everybody gets a meal because everybody eats at the same
time.
Glad to talk to you on Mochi yesterday.
I realized I forgot to say my name during the meet and
greet, but I'll continue lurking and watching your streams
from my hotel team.
Oh, yes, thank you.
I keep traveling for work.
Yes.
I'm glad that you had that.
That the con just happened to be right where you were
working.
Thank you, Chow!
Watching in my car because part of the building I work and
caught fire!
And my office is flooded from the firefighters putting the
fire out.
Good news is I get paid for my full hours this week.
Oh, I'm glad you're safe though.
Holy cow.
Stop going off of time, start going off of time.
Yes, food.
It's already more coherent than the glove plan.
Hey, the time glove was a foolproof plan.
Trust!
The time glove was just a mobile...
Uh...
What are those?
A sundial.
The time glove was just a mobile sundial!
And nobody can...
Nobody is ready for the future.
Today's my birthday!
Am...
Now 37!
One of the elder eyeballs.
However, I'm 6!
I'm hoping to replace my Ectoplasm with everyone by watching
the movie.
R&A's happy birthday!
I'm so sorry, you're sick on your birthday, no!
That's so sad, but I hope you feel better soon, and then you
can get some good cake or something.
Something yummy.
Speaking of birthdays, someone's is out in a couple weeks.
Can you guess who?
No.
Wait, are Mario and Luigi twins?
Do they have the same birthday?
Johnny?
No!
Actually, I don't know Johnny's birthday.
I have to make one up for him.
We can make one up.
When should Johnny's birthday be?
When should Johnny's birthday be, you guys?
Alan wake down
Mario Putago Wait April 30th Oh my gosh I was just thinking
that too Wait hold on let me look up Johnny Akiba's real
birthday Let's see Johnny Akiba We're just Shisaki baby
let's see does it say when his birthday is no no it doesn't
dang gosh my johnny looks so much like him though for real
co-jimbo you're letting us down how i cannot i cannot make
my my cat johnny
I cannot make him the real real Johnny unless you give me
his disguise I need his I need everything about him I need
his I need his blood type uh should be the day when the
first crapper was invented that's called that's called 1
million BC where someone dug a hole in the ground and in it.
Hey, Aminto darling.
That's doctor to you.
Thank you.
The first John.
Well, I don't know.
I love Johnny Sasaki.
Yeah.
But MGS4 release day.
Oh.
That's a good one.
Oh, whoops.
Wait, what did I just...
There we go.
Let's see.
MGS4 release date.
Almost forgot there's a new trend of people sharing vocal
stems.
Got any new ones stuck in your head recently?
No.
Trend of sharing vocal stems.
Besides my usual, I don't know if I have any new ones.
Dr. Director,
D-D-R-D-R-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-June
12th was when the MGS4 came out.
Wait, yeah.
Looking forward to seeing you next weekend at Vexpo!
I was lucky enough to get your mean greet.
I'll see you there!
Crayon made!
Thank you for the pink.
Thank you so much.
I'm off work now for two weeks, so I can actually catch you
live.
join the cat talk but I'm sure my dog thinks she's a cat
sometimes pet talk is all the same no oh my gosh did you
guys see the cute little photo booth things I I I've never
done this before hold on there is my there is my you can go
to the photo booth at at Vexpo and you can take here I'll
just do all of Densetsu so you guys can see ours.
They're so cute.
Sorry, I've been coughing recently.
I don't think I'm allergic to Johnny, but...
I was, like, coughing in the middle of the night, and then I
was coughing all this morning, and I was like, oh, no, am I
sick?
No!
But I think it's because he crawls under everything and gets
the dust.
Look at these.
Aren't they so cute?
Look, you can...
You can do the photo booth with us.
We all did them differently.
Mine are all on the right side.
Phoebe did them correctly where it shows the person
standing.
And then Vicky covered the person.
All three of us did them differently.
But I also was thinking, I was like, oh, well, it's easier
stand in one spot the entire time right maybe i don't know
vicky did it right i think i think i'm right too no we're
all right because i think the the the mecha chameleon person
is supposed to be you and then vicky's covering you and
phoebe is the one that is not covering you and as a proper
example And then for me, I mixed it up.
Yeah, Vicky hit the dab.
Yeah.
But I didn't even notice when I did it.
I was like, oh, okay, I'm done.
Also, whose birthday is it in a few weeks?
Me!
It's my birthday soon!
And I will have an announcement about it next week.
About what we'll be doing next week.
Oh, gosh.
That's too soon.
I have much, much to prepare.
Yeah.
Announcement.
I know I'll be 19 again.
I'm going to be 19 number times.
Wow.
Yeah.
So we'll, we'll, we'll, we'll talk more about my birthday
next week, though.
Yes.
Yay.
Cool.
19 forever.
And that means forever.
You'll never be able to legally drink in the US.
I know, right?
That's okay.
I get the happy juice at the bar.
Is that a Sandlot reference?
I don't think I've seen that movie.
I know it.
But I've never seen it.
Kids from the movie Sandlot forever.
Wait, really?
I don't think I've seen it.
It's a classic.
Yeah, I know.
Wait, you're killing me, Smalls?
It's also from the Sandlot?
Wherever is the sandlot.
Really?
It's about the kids.
Them kids.
It's about them kids, right?
I was just trying to put extra emphasis on people that try
to guess how many times I've been 19.
But you don't need to know that now, do you?
Because the number stays the same regardless of the year.
Okay?
So you don't need to know, you don't need to...
You don't need to...
You don't need to worry your pretty little head over that,
okay?
Yes, Minto, whatever you say, Minto.
That's director to you.
Okay.
It's director.
Director.
Okay.
Control!
I'm excited to be playing again.
We just made it to a new area where Dr. Darling should be
around or something.
Yeah.
So, we have a doctor darling and yeah the labs the labs the
labs we're i i don't quite remember if we're trying to find
him we're trying to find some lady who who knows something
oh gosh i have my brain i'm into the happy juice you are my
happy juice happy happy happy happy Marshall, she's the
lady, right?
Yes, yes, yes.
Head of operations.
The hotel I remember.
We're past the hotel.
Sorry, I think I just heard Johnny.
Is?
He's probably fine.
Yeah, we're looking for answers, and we ain't leaving
without them, whether we like it.
Yeah, we're looking for answers on our brother still, where
that guy is what's going on what what happened we're looking
at answers for everything so shall we get into it continue
game there was something though last time i was trying to
find oh my gosh you guys alan wake 2 is now available there
was uh i was trying to find like an area to save gg easy oh
yeah and thank you for the super job um there was one lab
that i skipped so i do want to go back and see it but i
believe will probably be ambushed so that will be kind of
sad probably yeah we're here yeah yeah yeah all right hold
on i'm gonna look at the controls again uh let's see um this
week i plan on playing this twice so I should... Okay,
melee's V.
And we also started this sick skill tree.
Not under assets.
I don't remember where it was.
It wasn't under loadout.
What am I missing?
The his sniper.
Disgusting.
Multimedia.
Hotline.
Ash train.
Oh, that's right.
We did try to go into the ash train maze and i did we watch
this i'm averse to using objects of power i don't want to
lean on things i ultimately that's the control point oh
that's right thank you but the ashtray and the cigarette
smoking there forever have their uses the ashtray maze they
conjure is an impossibly changing labyrinth that no one but
the binder and those the binder invites so the ashtray is a
hint on how the things we hid in dimensional research the
things darling studies darling the danger and the risk
involved how's the audio by the way for every measure of
security and protection i could bring to the table the maze
hands down is our strongest lock i gave darling and his
chosen crew license to pass through the maze good thank you
I've started to think I should remove that license.
Oh.
Oh, drama.
Wait.
It was a...
It was Trench and Darling, though.
Was it Darling?
They had, like, a mega fight.
Right?
They were, like, upset with each other.
Fiznam!
DD, mega do do.
Where did we come from?
We came from this way, for sure.
And I got ambushed in here.
here
and wait I learned something new and I oh there it is I want
to go back to the labs oh actually I feel like we'll
probably go back though no so we'll just we'll just keep
going
this room is crazy This room...
This room is crazy.
It's very cool.
The locations in this game are very cool.
I saw some people in the comments kind of like...
Not enjoying how much the game is in notes.
Which I can understand, but...
I guess I am more understanding of it because you have
everybody that you would talk to like this.
This lady is literally clipping through the ceiling.
we really can get much information from.
T.D.
Megadoodle.
It's also my birthday.
Ruby, Ruby, Ruby, Ruby, Ruby, Ruby, Ruby, Ruby.
Happy birthday!
I've got my propeller hat and lollipop ready.
Let's go.
I also didn't notice this room before.
What is that over there?
Red means scary.
Notes also help build the history and SCP feel.
I agree.
I can understand it not being everybody's cup of tea, but...
I don't mind it so much.
I tend to like it.
That's right.
I wanted to make the construct...
Was it the spin?
Spin.
Pierce.
Precise charge shot that penetrates armor and enemies at any
range.
That could be huge.
And then my mods.
upgrade wait I can
pierce is the sniper I think I want that
here's my skill tree hello doctor darling hello basically a
sniper rifle right yeah yeah I don't know how I feel about
it being a charged weapon though right and we have no
ability points So we can't get anything anyway.
But that's okay.
What else we got in here?
Anything?
Okay, E was to levitate and throw.
Hold on.
There was one thing.
How did I...
Sorry, I'm looking at the controls again.
Like I said, I'm going to play twice this week.
So I shouldn't be for...
My brain is extra scrambled this week.
Because I have been preparing so much behind the scenes.
There's a gun construct.
You're going to...
Hello?
Really?
I'm excited.
Hmm.
Let's see.
What was it?
Oh, Q.
That's right.
We learned shield.
I have that now.
Launch was what I just did.
What was it that I just used to go on everything?
It's not melee, right?
Oh, it is.
Okay, good.
My bad.
Okay.
This looks like...
Whoa, what is this?
Wait, this looks like the astral planes that we've been like
going into.
I'm doing all the, uh...
Like little things to enhance my abilities.
Oh, astral plane exhibition!
I was right!
exhibition was originally built for the astronauts to use as
a training location.
A place to grow accustomed to the sights and sounds of the
astral plane before diving into the real thing.
We could have done a better job with it, but was being
stingy with the budget.
However, say his name.
However, once we discovered the we decided to repurpose the
place.
Similar to how zoos hope familiar surroundings will affect
the well-being of their animals, we hope to observe the
behavior and environment i keep hearing thinking i'm hearing
my cat similar to its home dimension so far it just breaks
everything we put it with but rome wasn't built in a day
refer to file blah blah for full report crocheting my
partner a blanket while watching ah well thanks for watching
new naming conventions have been established for the astral
entity known as astral spike outdated terms on this report
have been redacted.
I see.
Okay, interesting.
What is this?
My show is on.
Oh!
Everybody watch.
Watch my show.
Oh my god!
Wait, this is so cool!
Adlibs find some of these over-centered Their docks would be
kind of fun.
My bad.
Hope you guys weren't enjoying that.
Oh.
Introduction to Paranatural Topics.
An early hypothesis was that the mindscape of the astral
plane is subjective.
But that was fast-proven wrong.
It's an actual place.
Not a construct of the mind.
I was.
But then one could argue that that's the case with all
regions.
reality.
We've been able to record footage of the astral plane by
monitoring the brain activity of those experiencing.
That is the only concrete material that has come out of the
astral plane expeditions.
Apart from one shocking exception.
Yes.
In the astral plane footage, we're always in the vicinity of
the pyramid.
We've concluded that this, not the entire plane, is what the
board controls.
We have glimpsed.
Wait, I don't think I've ever noticed the pyramid.
Native species, always in the distance, and yet, contact was
made.
We don't have footage of this, a technical malfunction, but
when one of our astral knots returned, a brain cloud, an
astral feud, had hitchhiked a ride in his head.
It ruptured out, killing the subject in question.
It's a relentless predator, pursuing thoughts, minds, lethal
to those the entity feeds on.
proper containment protocols are to be observed super chat
was amazing don't hurry very much appreciate it thank you so
much oh I forgot that all these people do be talking they do
be yapping whoa
whoa wait wow whoa wow I can't believe they keep that thing
here oh my gosh oh my eyes oh are we going in do we have to
go calm it or something oh geez oh why are we doing this
yeah they kept one for us guys and it oh shield your eyes
please oh my gosh Oh, it's so bright.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
That's not what I meant to do!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Oh my god.
Oh, my eyes, my eyes, please.
Ah!
Bye!
Oh, oops.
I thought it was gonna shut the other door.
I thought it was gonna shut...
Oops.
Oh, my eyes, though.
Holy moly.
Okay, we're back here.
That's fine.
We could just skip everything.
I don't have to re-watch that, right?
I think I have it still in my... Okay.
I think I just gotta run through.
And close the door once I'm through.
Or something.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm so sorry.
This part is awful to look at.
Oh, wait.
I need to do something with you?
Why is there no...
Why isn't there a thing to shut it on this side?
What's this do?
Oh.
Exactly what...
Okay.
Don't fight the blobs.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, he's still there.
Uh, you.
Ah!
I don't know what that did.
What did I just do?
Oh!
Wait.
No, I don't know what it just did.
I don't know what it just did.
I did something.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Uh, what is that?
What is this?
Thanks.
Oh, gosh.
I'm trapped.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, we gotta go find how to power it.
Okay.
This is scary.
I see one.
I see them.
Okay.
Alright, alright.
Beep, beep, beep.
Uh, what do I need to get?
Wait.
Um.
Wait, close that door.
Oh my gosh.
Hold on, I'm gonna look from here.
Oh my gosh!
It closed the doors!
Beew, beew, beew, beew, beew, beew!
Uh...
I'm a little confused.
What they're asking of me.
Wait, does this one close up here?
No.
Oh.
How do I get him in there?
there you know I think I have to get him in in there but he
like is so fast to sounds like a windshield wiper I sure
hope not I sure hope your windshield wiper doesn't sound
like that you need to change it
see and then probably we'll use whatever that thing is okay
all right let's go Weeeeee!
Whoop!
Alright, run, run, run, run, run.
Let's see, now how...
What would he want?
Oh, shoot.
Over there?
It's like a maybe he like...
Okay, hold on.
Whoa, whew, whew, whew, whew, whew, whew.
Come here?
Ah!
He wants me, yeah!
Yeah.
Someone left the phone off the hook.
Wait.
Oh, there we go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Yeah!
Oh, yeah!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What if I just...
I won't let you free it.
thing nice job director yeah what were they doing with that
thing they're trying to harness its energy we need backup
down here oh it's Marshall hello Marshall are you still
there shit she was just there we need to hurry yeah she's in
trouble I remember them saying that last time they knew
you'd try that and said No.
Yeah, truly.
What is going on in here?
Oh, gosh.
There's so many guys.
All right, hold on.
I'm observing the...
Oh.
Hiss clusters heal other enemies.
Destroy them to make the fight easier.
Is that a hiss cluster right there?
It must be, no.
No.
Okay.
Eh.
They're not coming up this way.
What gun am I using?
I can't even tell, actually.
I don't know what gun I'm using at the moment.
Yeah!
You're using the shotgun.
Okay, I gotta change.
I don't remember.
Oh, two.
Oh, I changed that and sorry.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry, guys.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, for now we'll just long range them.
For now, we can just do it from long range until...
Yeah.
Holy cow.
Who else is down there?
There you are.
Number key.
I was trying, but nothing is working.
Oh, that's right.
It kind of has like an animation, right?
Oh, no.
I thought it did.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
Scared the heck out of me.
It's F?
Oh, thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay.
I forgot.
Can I grab these when they shoot them?
No, you cannot.
You cannot.
Oh, my God.
Oh my god.
I'm already down.
I'm down.
Yeah.
Take that guy down.
Where are they at rest?
Yeah, it's the upgrade we don't have yet to grab the rocket
launchers.
Ripperoni.
Oh my gosh.
Can I, please?
Can I... My hands are trembling.
Please.
I'm just trying to kill you.
I'll tell you what it's...
Oh.
It was...
Um...
Hmm.
Oh, it's here.
Shatter projectile, sure.
Okay.
Don't get me with your stinking...
There we go.
Oh, no!
You got lucky.
Again?
This guy's lucky.
Where's the other one?
What is down here anyway?
These seats are freaky.
I thought it...
Oh, they're like...
Brain chair, yeah.
Oh.
I'll go get him.
Come here?
Oh, you got so lucky!
Wait, why can't I- on you!
Whatever.
What's this?
Oh, that's something I think maybe did come to me.
I think it was like a... There's still guys around.
What's this?
Before using the recording devices, please ensure the
following safety measures are met.
Recording chair.
Ensure the volunteer is securely fastened to the chair.
Ensure the hood is placed over a volunteer's head.
This will prevent the volunteer from taking in visual
stimuli during the record process.
quality of captured footage.
This also prevents recording technicians from viewing the
volunteer's face which undergoes muscle spasms during the
recording that some consider upsetting.
Check if the volunteer is comfortable.
Activate the recording apparatus after recording is
complete.
Check volunteer cognitive ability using the provided
questionnaire.
Reminder, don't be alarmed if the length of recorded footage
exceeds the volunteer's period of consciousness.
Astral dilation is a known issue.
If any problems arise from this process, contact your
supervisor.
here oh there's another guy oh another guys where's our next
victim i mean pal hey pal hey pal where'd you go you were
around here wait oh there oh more can i get him
This room seems to have a lot.
It's a really cool looking room, too.
Slice them in half.
Oh.
Ooh.
Spooky.
Why?
Did they run out of lights?
Imagine this being your cubicle.
What is it?
Something not very nice sounds like it's up there.
I'm a bit nervous.
Oh, it's this one.
Oh, wow, wow!
I'm going to recalc.
Oh, my gosh.
Can I?
Where is he?
Come on.
Can I take that?
Oh, I can.
Yeah.
So close.
We got him though?
We got him?
Oh.
Yeah.
A thingy.
I control.
I cleanse this point.
Get in that brain helmet.
Wow.
Hello, Readers.
Thank you so much.
Thank you so much for the rest.
Hey!
We've encountered heavy resistance.
We've fallen back to the lock department.
All agents are ordered to converge here.
Speak with Marshall and the intercom in the next elevator.
Whoa!
It's a brain!
Wow!
It's a brain.
A captive audience.
Oh, oh.
Oh!
What is that?
I'm scared of your voice.
missions thanks for the gift and you guys thank you so much
thank you thank you hold on i want to open these group think
rethinking group think oh what is oh my gosh what was that
uh pluribious that show i i finished i finished the first
season valerius thank you silly thank you Pluribus.
Pluribus.
Yeah, yeah.
I finished it today too.
I really like it.
I can't wait for the next season.
I think it ends on a good kind of a good cliffhanger that
makes me excited.
This study extends the works of Irving Janus, Robert Barron,
and others by proposing strong casual links between
groupthink and the passive or active use of telepathy.
I love when plurib, plurbeus says it's plurib in time.
To prove these connections, the parapsychological, cycle,
cycle, psych, psych, parapsychology department carried out
variations of this, of Solomon, uh, uh, hash, original
conformity experience using a telepathic individual as the
subject see experiments redacted for details extensive
qualitative and quantitative data resulting from these
experiments was then used to identify telepathic
interference within the group further empirical findings
suggest measures can be taken to safeguard against
telepathic influence on behaviors by engaging in redacted
rather boldly this paper stands to revolutionize decades of
group think theory and provide new directions for further
experimentation on the mind, including manipulations of
redacted and redacted.
Interesting.
The world will turn to mass.
Was there anything else I missed in this area?
I guess, what were these?
When I, okay, yeah, I was gonna say, when I cleanse the
area, I imagine these ugly bits.
Whoa, what's that?
How do I get you?
Oh, I did miss something, though.
Okay, good job.
Let's go.
This is definitely how we're supposed to use the stairs.
Group thinking, Ash's conformity experiments are real
psychological experiments.
I found them fascinating.
Worth reading if you get the chance.
I...
The way they described it seemed like it almost was a real
thing, so...
I can't grab it, right?
Director hitting the stanky leg.
Nadine, send this to Research for Analysis.
My pre-cognitive powers.
Urgent!
Dr. Darling, last night I had a dream!
In the dream I was given the solution to a staffing problem
I'd been presented with just yesterday.
problem is of confidential nature and must therefore remain
unclarified here but i can assure you that the method
through which i received this helpful information was
undeniably paranormal i can only draw the conclusion that i
possess exceptional precognitive cognitive abilities and as
such offer my services to the bureau's research teams we
must utilize my powers for the greater good signed mr
francis bertram yeah all right it came to be in a dream You
know what also came to in a dream?
Twilight.
His cluster.
So now we have to make sure we kill these things.
Astronaut program.
Did I not read this?
This report serves as an introductory guide to the astronaut
program.
Including candidate requirements, training practices, and
astral research procedures.
Astronauts are chosen individuals who explore and
document...
Yeah, the astral plane by making physical contact with the
X-ray light block.
in the hypnosis lab, a section of the parapsychology
division.
Physical and physical, physical, phys, phys, phys, phys,
phys, psych, psychological training.
I can't read!
Oh, this was the side mission.
Got it, got it.
It's vital for the repeated transitions between planes known
as dives.
After each dive, astronauts must undergo a...
redacted session in the cognitive recording chairs to record
their experience in the plane.
Ah, that's why they're there.
What about the...
So they're the volunteers.
I mean, though, the words.
What do they mean?
I don't know anymore.
Yeah.
Gather data has conclusively proven that redacted within the
astral plane vary widely between astronauts.
What...
What are they doing in the astral plane?
Redacted!
On rare occasions, these dives can result in losses often
occurring when teams encounter aggressive astral entities.
You want to redact it in the astral plane.
Why are some of these moving swinging though?
It's freaking me out.
So we have many doors.
Many ways to go.
This goes to...
Hypnosis Lab!
Oh yeah!
This is just like my Japanese anime.
And this goes to...
Um...
Extrasensory Lab!
Where do you guys want to go?
It's for the side mission.
Oh!
Okay, let's do it then.
I'm glad we're close usually sometimes or rather the side
missions I don't know how far away they'll be or not they're
your friends I
see it another object of power they're just standing there
mesmerized by it this one's freaking me out a little bit.
I'm so glad you're the director of Dojinchi Labs.
Of course, of course.
Photoshop a picture of me in there.
Everybody do be staring.
Put little Minky plushy in there.
This is scary.
What the heck is this thing?
It kind of looks relaxing, actually.
Like a head massage.
Oh, oh it's that thing.
Oh, what's this?
Oh.
Okay.
I see.
Coffee.
Lots of classifieds, lots of classifieds.
Too darling.
Monday 10 filed these urgent.
You guys aren't gonna, like, turn on me, right?
Astral Blip.
Nice.
Ooh!
I don't think the kids are alright, you guys.
She didn't see the password.
I might have.
I did see...
I took note of this.
But I'm just looking.
looking around.
Will it open the door?
Yes.
So it was, uh, this is what VTuber meet and greets look like
to the dad bringing his son to the VTuber card.
Don't say that.
Don't man.
When my mom would take me to anime conventions, I remember
I remember It would be so bad
Oh Isn't that it?
Wait
Isn't that what I just made?
Am I wrong?
That is what I made Oh the outside ring as well Oh, oops My
bad
Ah!
They're, um, they are...
Yeah, they're, they're solid.
Okay.
No!
Oh.
Ah!
Wait, the...
What's happening?
New Bureau alert.
Oh, it's that thing.
Okay.
So close!
Ah.
Okay.
Oh no, no, I'm so close!
Ah, mama.
Ah, I did it, I did it, I did it!
Okay, wow, that was a fun puzzle.
I like that one.
You guys aren't gonna turn on me, right?
When I touch this?
You guys are gonna be like, Never mind, that was mine!
That was my x-ray machine.
Whatever.
It looks like the things when you get an x-ray and you put
it on the, like, Like the board that's lit up.
Oh, wait, you looked at me for a second.
Oh, no, you didn't.
You're just twitching in place.
This guy, though.
What if I shoot them?
What if I shoot them, though?
Of course they wouldn't.
You were the director.
Yeah, nobody would attack me right.
Try it.
He looked the worst, okay?
That's why I took him out.
Oh!
He looked the worst out of all of them!
Please state your name for the record.
Mint Phantom.
And you are aware that exposure to the astral plane can
result in death, disability...
He ain't gonna be in control too!
Cognitive collapse, loss of ego, and partial to full
dimension?
Full dimension?
I am.
And you acknowledge that your use of the from Conduit, aka
the X-ray light box.
Surely voluntary.
Yes, I do.
Perfect.
Your suit is good.
Yes, yes.
It is an X-ray light box.
Okay, they said that before and it just didn't register to
me.
Wait, I'm gonna try taking them all out then.
It's okay.
You'll feel better.
You'll feel better after I do this.
Wait, what if they return to normal though?
Okay, we'll leave half.
Don't look at the friends up front.
they might be like oh thank you doc you saved us and some of
them might be like doc you took away my favorite toy and i
really hate that you seize oh what did that say gold were
the ones that i can't shoot right i think
what am i seizing oh golden copy mpc variation it's have as
a health Barlow.
What the F?
F?
I'm Fing you?
What does that mean?
Wait, I didn't- Oh!
Hold- F to seize enemies!
Oh!
He's now mine!
Oh wow!
Okay, okay!
I was- VTuber can't read.
Well, actually I need that.
Come here.
I think my guy is dead.
My buddy.
Oh, oops.
I'm too good at the game.
F you.
F you!
You're mine though?
Wee!
F him.
F you.
You're mine though?
Yeah!
Whoa, this is huge!
But I don't get health from them anymore, so that's kind of
sad.
Oh, not bad.
I'm so sorry.
Oh.
X-rays now bound!
Nice!
Okay.
Oh, this seems kind of fun.
Where'd they go?
Oh!
you guys it wasn't me i think your brains were fried when i
took over the object yeah oops it wasn't me it wasn't me oh
tummy ache they all died of tummy ache well nice now we can
uh do that that's fine
and what's over here this lab only they had some tums they
honestly all offices should have tums no what's this where
does everything go what's in here there must be information
cool things open it up
sensory tank Darling here!
I'm like, darling!
And ginger tea.
Oh yeah.
The gas station sushi claims more victims.
Some of you were curious why I had these sensory deprivation
tanks installed.
Okay, I thought I'd set- I cannot speak.
I feel like my tongue is swollen.
I thought I'd shed some light on the subject.
Maybe some of you have heard of a Dr. Yoshimi Tokui.
The man behind the largely, no, sorry, hugely popular guided
imagery experience tapes.
Apparently his tapes go beyond the normal meditative
qualities of such things, but create genuine hallucinatory
visions in some listeners, or so the reports say.
We brought these tanks in to test Dr. Tokui's tapes for
ourselves.
Plus, there may be some stress-relieving uses for the staff
down the road.
I think we all could benefit from some, from some things.
time in the dark and closed space, don't you think?
If you have any more questions, feel free to stop by my
office.
You know where it is.
Actually, I don't.
And I'm struggling.
Wait, so we can go in the tank?
I can become...
Whoa.
Interesting.
Dr. Tokui Investigation.
This is so SCP.
Yeah, let's get hallucinating, baby.
Dr. Yoshimi Tokui, a Japanese citizen residing in Tokyo, has
produced a series of guided imagery experience audio
recordings that have gained notable popularity around the
globe.
Due to his unusually swift rise in fame along with reports
of vivid redacted, accompanying the use of his tapes,
investigation sector staff were asked to look into Dr.
Tokui's background.
We found no past incident with an altered occurrence, nor
any evidence of involvement.
with an altered organization however agents that attended a
signing event reported redacted when hearing dr tokui speak
something tells me you'll recognize the doctor va really we
recommend that the research team obtained an audio recording
of dr tokui's voice and perform any and all relevant
analysis is based on the findings the investigation sector
will determine next steps regarding dr tokui as well as his
eligibility for the prime candidate program
These look...
Baby!
The symbols, what do they mean?
Oops.
Oh, oh, they're like psychic things, right?
You put up a thing and then the other person is supposed to
guess?
Did they get it right?
Wait.
Zero plus star?
Oh.
but not quite.
Yeah, Cleverware and test cards.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was pretty close.
The Ghostbusters thing.
Was it in Ghostbusters?
I don't remember.
What is this up there?
Am I going to get ambushed in here?
Is there anybody in here?
It's red, so I feel like...
Didn't I have a flashlight, or am I crazy?
This one's green.
Let's get in.
Oh, the opening scene!
Wait, now I think I remember.
No flashlight in this game.
Just kidding.
I saw...
Oh, I thought that we would have an audio recording.
No!
Oh!
Okay.
Wait, I want to try it.
Take the tape taken by Dr. Darling.
Where is it?
What is there?
Oh, speaker.
Where is the tape taken by Dr. Darling?
Not in here, maybe?
Uh...
Oh, wait.
Tab is my map, isn't it?
Yeah.
Um...
Oh, that's really far away.
Find the tape taken to the ritual office.
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, my.
Maybe we can track it another time.
Anybody want to...
Yeah, Western Blend!
Western Blend!
He'll be going there anyway, I think?
Oh, okay.
If that's the case.
Awesome.
If not?
Whatever.
I think...
Can't find your office.
Watch your step.
Avoid my...
Modern technology!
The kids these days, they crave analog.
I mean, it's not analog, but I hear, like, old iPods are
back in and stuff.
Now, I did get some ability stuff, so let's...
We could do...
50% launch damage.
Shield.
Or was I...
Was it energy that I was going for?
See!
Plus 5% to seize duration.
Oh, so they're only seized for a certain amount of time.
Bring back Walkman.
Walkman still exists, though.
Next, you'll see them use an old MP3 again.
Walkman still exists, actually.
Holden launched up to three objects.
Crazy.
launch damage.
This is a melee.
Health.
Shield?
Oh yeah, that's right.
When released, shield debris hits the other enemies.
That's pretty nice.
I might do more energy, though.
Nice.
And then, um...
Not collectibles.
Where was a...
What other mods do we get?
Anything good?
What do I have right now?
Launch energy cost minus 11.
Shields get good with Surge Dash.
Yeah, maybe I'll save up for that.
Where was it that I could that I could Um...
Eh?
Was it in here?
Oh yeah, here we go.
Astral Construct.
Construct Pierce.
Okay, we still need more Source.
That's what we're...
Okay, because I figured we had enough blip because I got in
a couple of them.
And then Ritual Impulse if we want to do Construct Spin.
Okay, there we go.
I'm good now.
I'm good to go.
J2J.
Okay.
Is that the inner calm we need to talk to you on?
Seems like it.
What else is around here?
We have Parakeensiology, Astral Exhibition.
This is where I came from.
But I'm just kind of...
It's still kind of messed up looking.
Oh, wait!
Oh, I see!
This is...
Oh, I see, I see.
So this should go to the...
This probably goes to the...
one ah yes yes yes yes yes and then that one lab that i
wanted to go to was like downstairs over there ah yes yes
yes i literally saw a random thumbnail of some guy unboxing
a third gen ipod with gloves on it like it was an
archaeological artifact well i think like i think like apple
stores now count those as like or not those like they count
they call like older phones vintage and
Marshall can you hear me yes I can hear you who is this my
name is Jesse Faden I'm coming to help did she just go
crosshead she's got that right we do need to talk oh shoot
more of you oh shoot really oh oh it's these guys oh no oh
shoot Wham-wham!
Yeah!
We took my first guy!
Oh, he did.
Just in time.
Is the elevator here?
Oh, yes.
Very clean.
Yeah, that was great.
Oh.
Why does it look like she's wearing something from like
outer wilds?
Looks like something Garbo would wear.
Oh.
Rubber duck supplement Discovered in the home of Agent
Redacted after his young daughter Complained of being
followed by her rubber duck Crime scene Crime scene cleaner
According to Agent Redacted The matter was ignored Believed
to be the result of a child's imagination Until he began to
hear the quacking at night Yeah he didn't make it to the
toilet Entire The I read After discovering the item hiding
in his daughter's closet, he brought it to the Bureau for
study.
Update, it was discovered that Agent Redacted was bringing
known perinatural materials into his home, illegally taking
them from outside the oldest house.
How this may have affected the creation of an altered item
is being investigated.
Agent Redacted has been terminated permanently.
And we have the light box.
The image is a light box used to examine x-ray images.
from the light box.
The information on the image belongs to a patient named
Redacted.
They hated that kid.
Terminated.
That guy needs more fiber in his diet.
Yeah.
Eat more fiber.
You'll end up like this guy, unfortunately.
The object allows perutilitarians to forcefully seize an
individual's Redacted.
The seized individuals become redacted to the user.
They become in love with the user.
The effect lasts redacted.
Once released, the sea is redacted as a result of the
psychic trauma.
Oh, so they die.
The janitor named redacted bound.
Oh, bound the object at St. Anne's Hospital and redacted.
Soon the building's documents were redacted by him.
Oh my God.
The Bureau of Dispatch and Emergency Response Team to
redacted, the perpetrator, and redacted the item.
Can't you just say that they, like, took the item?
Why is that part redacted?
Fatality is numbered in the redacted.
In the blank, does it, like, what?
It could be tens, could be hundreds.
Could be thousands?
Marshall's eager to speak with you, ma'am.
She's just down the hall.
This super chat is redacted.
This super chat is awesome!
Thank you!
Oh, oh, hey, if you guys were all up here, couldn't you see
me fighting for my life down here?
choose to help hello excuse you so much redacted happening i
know my goodness
everything must be redacted they budgeted for too much black
ink that must be it that must be it they're they're like
dang we gotta we gotta use this stuff
i wonder what it feels like just being floating up in the
air like this one looks more well doesn't look uncomfortable
i would like to be a floating person like that that one's
not so great either but this looks like the worst this looks
like the worst way to be to be floating this one's okay too
this one's actually the the best probably.
Minto Redactido.
Don't you float already?
You know
I...
Luck and probability.
Lucky cat!
You okay?
Oh no.
Oh, did they have a thousand paper cranes too?
Whoa!
Can I touch that?
Let's play Blackjack!
Oh, fish.
Everybody okay?
Oh, you're right?
Guy's going through it.
What's this?
There you are.
I was starting to worry.
What did I do?
Oh, no.
I want that.
Thank you.
Lucky Clover.
Oh, I see.
If it's turned upside down, all the luck falls out.
So it has to be right side up.
up famously minto is a paranormal entity that makes you fall
and redacted with her
fall in fall in shaving cream
wow can i have any of these hello hi what's this oh level
clearance five
hello congratulations on your appointment director faden i'm
helen marshal head of bureau operations zachariah is dead
then and i assume you found his gun just call me jesse
trench told me to find you he said you could help and he
told you this through the hotline makes sense none of this
phase is hurt cool really here's the situation darling
created the hra is in a lab nearby we need more if we're
gonna survive this attack my range just can't secure the lab
alone hra is the things that make you not turn into his her
floaties seems to know what's going on here she could know
about Dylan I can clear out the hiss I'll be your firepower
that's a good answer is she testing me drawing his systems
in place to protect his labs this should help you get past
them we'll talk more after you clear out the hiss okay
rangers let her through we'll have to lock the door behind
you oh i'm sorry but we can't risk a breach well i don't
like the sound of that this is can we change the lighting in
here i heard it steals your soul don't worry we've already
sold yours by working here yeah the big green yeah these
things this that thing that she's wearing that's the what a
Those are the things that make it so you don't turn into one
of them.
Playing this game but ignoring the collectibles because Mint
reads all of them for me.
Could eventually play this game for myself but for now I
watch my play it.
Thank you!
Well, I sometimes miss them so you should play it too.
Oh, they're already on me?
If they get closer, I could start...
Wait, is there a thing that heals them?
Oh gosh, there's a lot of guys, huh?
Okay, I'm gonna have to start going in, huh?
What?
What a...
I see rangers over there.
You have to help them.
Where's my...
Where'd he go?
What the?
I didn't kill him.
Ah!
Oh, there he is.
There it is!
There's a thing!
No.
I won't let you get away.
Ah, shoot.
Where'd it go?
Are you low enough?
Ah!
Trying to grab some health.
For a second.
Give me a second, everybody.
I'm injured.
The director is hurting.
You.
Oh, not you.
And we'll turn you into my little slave!
Meow.
Yes.
Oh, friend.
Uh, was that a...
What I think it was.
Everybody's alive here, right?
We're all good?
Oh, there's more?
Your friend?
Uh, hello?
Uh, why are we not doing anything?
Raiders, thank you for the- Ah!
Watch out!
Don't get close!
Oh my god!
Gosh, they scare me.
I don't like these.
Wait, I can even change you into one of my- One of my team
guys?
Oh my gosh.
No!
We lost a guy!
Oh, I watched it happen!
No!
Oh, we can clear it now.
We can cleanse it.
Cleanse, cleanse, cleanse!
Thank you for all the gifts with you guys!
Thank you so much!
Oh.
What is this?
He's almost dead?
We got him?
Oh, shoot.
We have a guy left, yeah!
It's okay.
I could throw their bodies at them.
We have one guy left.
Hey, pick up these dots.
Eat these dots.
They taste good.
They make you feel better.
Thank you for the read.
Thank you!
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Fear my infinite pew pew.
I cleanse this area.
Sorry that nobody made it.
Just...
You don't feel worried at all!
It's just you!
Should we tell him?
I cleanse the area, unless there's more.
Synchronicity Lab.
Oh, that's exactly what that says.
What else we got around here?
We have...
Ooh.
Ritual Office.
We have...
Protective Studies.
Continue towards Darling's HRA Lab.
Yeah, but...
One second.
I want to check out these areas.
too he's chill yeah he's oh did
i come here before a shelter too oh my gosh it's so easy to
miss stuff sometimes you know get in the shelter get in the
shelter what's this threshold kids hiss warp this is the guy
that we just did right he wasn't so bad Telekinetically
shield themselves.
I see, I see, I see.
Interesting, okay.
Threshold kids.
With the recent arrival of redacted, there are certain
glaring gaps in the Bureau's ability to educate and raise a
young redacted.
They're a young boss.
Hope you play this twice a week.
It's addictive.
Good job, director.
Have a fun stream.
Thank you, Bonnie.
Thank you.
There are no other redacted for redacted.
to play with and redacted is expected to learn about a
frightening new con about a frightening new concept redacted
will require a slow redacted friendly kid friendly
introduction to perinatural topics with wait that we saw
that little cartoon with this in mind allow me to introduce
the threshold kids yeah a television show in which a cast of
cheerful puppets explain the dangers of living at the Bureau
but also show the fun side of the perinatural dog thank you
so much for the for the 10 gifted thank you so much э
budget would be minimal i took a few puppet making courses
at my local community kit theater hey sign me up i am a
puppet making professional i can do it i'm a professional we
have research staff we can have research staff build the
sets record the footage and even do the voices it will be
good for morale and i guarantee you redacted will respond
positively to these videos is this like her brother maybe we
can't expect a redacted to enjoyed lectures and people in
lab coats but as television has proven for years where kids
love puppets so maybe her brother was one of these kids that
watched these shows health boost wait whoa whoa wait what do
we have right now astral health oh yeah let's do this one
nice nice nice
what's this one projectile spread oh nice nice nice what's
this one oh damage while low on health 52 I mean damage nice
I get Dylan but why would they keep the other kids here I
mean Dylan can't be the only kid that has experienced
something you know that's It's very possible that others had
as well, you know.
That was the elevator, so...
Oh, let's go to the synchronicity lab.
Let's see what's going on over here.
Hi, thank you.
Hello.
If you take control of those enemy soldiers to fight for
you, what happens if you take control of enemy chefs,
painters, baristas, and masseuse?
Well, I don't know.
is it why why did we get a big big introduction to here i
was scared anything around it's really quiet oh the test
dummy one's wearing a dress why are you so fancy what are
you dressed up for wow that's over here yeah it's very quiet
no We've got a bedroom of...
Oh, this is the hotel!
I recognize that tiny, tiny, itty-bitty, teeny-weeny, super
small TV-weeny from anywhere.
What's going on there?
This one's broken, though.
It's kind of freaky.
Hello?
Okay.
I thought this was a control point.
For a second.
Okay.
I don't think I've noticed any...
Papers or anything.
Nothing to pick up.
Freaky noises.
Something broke out.
Ew, don't say it like that!
Ew, ew, ew, ew.
Wow, this place is so wet.
Where the heck are we?
Ah!
I see.
Oh!
Okay.
What was that noise?
This isn't available yet, but there's a separate secret in
this room.
Oh, I see.
Whoa.
My show is on.
Aha!
Finally.
Synchronicity experiment.
Summary.
Examination of Paranatural Topics Experimentation with
Global Synchronicity Summary As a test, television sets were
placed in a variety of locations around the world inside
rooms identically decorated The hypothesis was that by
identically altering the decor of every room and then
changing the channel in every room but one, that the single
differing television would spontaneously align the incoming
frequency to match its synchronized counterparts experiment
seemed like a failure until it was observed that the agents
responsible for arranging and monitoring these rooms were
all experiencing the same emotional turmoil as one
clinically depressed member on the team himself being
located in the eastern part of redacted parapsychological
examination of the agents proved the correlation
interestingly interestingly the phenomenon of synchronicity
did occur occur but not in the way we predicted funny the
cameras be me interesting room it definitely i i was already
told oh wait there's mirror testing what's down here oh no
clearance level six wait okay whoa something's going on here
whoa whoa whoa we're only clearance i don't remember two
three all right yeah i know i was told that there's a secret
mission but it feels like there's definitely much more in
that room regardless of whether you know that or not all
right protective studies
that looks not great down there that looks a little worse i
think we're at three right spin grouping efficiency caution
Why are we recording?
This is like that password that I made.
It's so funny to see the sealed off doors because you just
have to wonder what went wrong.
What happened and you know everything is sealed?
If it happened before all of this went to heck or you know?
Oh.
The dokey!
Ah!
It's the rubber dokey!
Wait.
Oh, wait, it's the rubber duckie that oh
Altered item number 52 a.e analysis session two I will begin
by he's stinky.
It's got like a aura about him Stinky dog No response next I
will introduce heat via a standard Bunsen burner
Okay.
Next, a series of solutions will be applied.
Each is a different value on the pH scale from 0 to 14.
Oh, wow.
I feel so immersed.
This audio is doing great.
No response to any value.
Next, I will attempt to communicate.
Can you understand me?
Can you understand my words?
Quack.
I can understand my words.
Whack.
Getting off mid-charts.
We'll need time to prepare further tests.
Silly ducky.
This looks bad.
This is a little spooky.
This way to the lab?
Okay.
You must like these HRAs.
Sounds like Darling built them.
And most of the things around here.
If Marshall can't help us with Dylan, he's our next best
bet.
Assuming he's not dead or taken over by the hiss.
I'm nervous.
There we have a door over there that can be opened.
And we have a thing here, too.
I'll open that.
Pattern.
Thank you.
Ah, it's this again.
It's this again.
Wait a second, though.
I'm curious about over here.
Oh, who's that?
Sound like a ha-ha.
What was that?
Let's go back over here.
Oh, oh, oh.
I'll take that.
Kiara!
Wait!
Wait, Kiwara's here?
For real?
Minto, are you enjoying this game?
I've been curious about it.
I am!
It's really interesting!
It's a lot of...
If you like SCP stuff, and the combat's really fun.
But there's a lot of lore about different items that are
kind of funky and...
like they do thing like they do like scp type stuff so i
hope you're doing so well my beautiful kiwawa yeah it's not
quite a horror game but it's got a little creepy elements um
i think if i can do it you can do it for sure yeah
it's quite fun actually i do i'm gonna go grab some more
water go to the little ghosties room so i will be you can
you can look at jesse for a bit oh we have to change her
outfit we have to we we're wearing this one today but we i
said each session we would change into a different outfit so
my channel now oh yeah everybody is key mama can you keep
everybody entertained thank you i'll be right back what's
happening What is there so?
What is happening?
What's happening?
Add some lime to the lemon.
What is going on?
Oh, what do you mean?
KFP!
I was being a troublemaker.
You take that back.
That's my Oshi you're talking about.
My Oshi can do no wrong.
I did not instigate this.
Scatter!
Hold on, I'm fixing my chair real quick!
Okay.
I believe her.
Oh my gosh, red lemon.
Why are you doing lemons?
Yippie KFP.
What is happening?
Wawa, I love you and I miss you.
Kiera may or may not have offered lemon juice.
KFP lemonade.
You guys are scaring me.
Is it pee or lemonade?
Mito, why is it so yellow?
Because it's lemonade.
Yes.
Got it.
Well, Kiara, I think I'm like a little bit in this game.
So maybe don't watch so much.
Sorry.
Easy puzzle, easy puzzle.
I understand it now completely.
Okay, bye!
Bye!
I love you!
Oh, we made it!
We made it!
You led me here.
Any idea how to make it work?
Activate the HRA machine.
Dimensions feedback loop too powerful for us to use.
Okay, so all of these like patterns were not viable.
Our way in?
Too strong?
Leaks out?
Charging variables?
Alright, hold on.
Boppy!
Beep, beep, beep!
Oh my gosh!
Here's we have a new problem.
We need to get the HRA machine working.
I've replaced a couple of spark plugs, but this looks a bit
more complicated.
Restart the punch card terminals and then activate the HRA.
Randomness isn't in his nature.
The punch cards.
The symbols.
The terminals.
How do they connect?
I'll see what I can do.
Okay, we need punch cards.
Two.
One, two.
Okay, that's a card.
Holy, okay.
We got three.
There's another card.
Okay.
All right.
Okay, this might give us some more insight on it too.
Black rock prisms are unique formations of black rock
distinct in both their shape and potency.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom.
While the density of black rock dampens Paranatural forces
The unique redacted structure of prism Retained frequencies
in the range Redacted to redacted Hurts with perfect
redaction Harmonization This report analysis Analyzes the
results of focusing a redacted Through a harmonized prism
onto a redacted Methods for imprinting of non-physical
fields onto redacted imbuing them with the properties of the
harmonized resonance redacted in the prism will be explored
and explained refer to the file redacted for the full report
sorry I actually didn't retain any of that Did I?
Okay, let's...
Okay, I'm looking for them.
I'm looking for them.
What's this?
The forest of positive interactions.
So I play this and get in the tank.
Oh, we found it!
Self-reflection can bring answers.
I read that somewhere.
Okay, four is up here because it's spooky.
and must be in a separate location.
We got the thing for the...
Sorry.
Looking forward to seeing your performance, Expo!
See you there!
Lemonade?
Hello?
Thank you.
I hope Kiara is secretly watching to hear the wonderful
singing.
Well, Kiara is also...
Black Rock Shooter is like Kiara's sister.
Because it's both Okay, Papa.
Under the new director, all reports must be a remix.
Anything about BlackRock?
Alright.
I'm guessing I got all of them, then?
Okay.
Each punch card should correspond to a turn.
Can we affect this?
So this one...
Okay.
or shot okay right so this one of these let's
just put it in but then not every single one is going to we
have not every single one has its own these whiteboard
drawings may be important
this part requires some thinking yeah i'm gonna need you to
shut up marshal okay so i can use my
I can kind of see it over here.
Wait,
hold on.
It looks like he was working on something to do with these
symbols.
Oh my god.
Are you going to yapp the entire time?
I'm trying to figure it out.
I thought something might be under here.
What?
Okay, never mind.
Yeah, just think faster.
Duh, dummy!
Shut up!
So this is not crossed out.
This is the same thing, but one is crossed out and one
isn't.
Wait, two power, what?
So is it like one... Okay, wait, hold on.
so one is going to be this one so okay okay I get it I get
it now so one will be this one it was also the first one on
the thing okay let me and then one two three four is going
to be that one right I think I think I understand wait wait
they're two different are they wait I'm confused
oh no they are i thought that oh i thought it was giving me
like you know one will be this try different combinations
shut up please and then like two three we don't know but
fourth is this one but two three is written over here maybe
oh but if we do those it'll be too strong okay hold on let's
just try it let's just try it um the one this is two this
one and then three is this one
or it could be the wall
oh wait oops i was just there
maus bad marshal yeah yeah i'm gonna try this and then Wait,
yeah, this one and then this one, and if not, I'll switch
the two.
Should I get it to work?
Why doesn't he write down the proper thing?
Oh, this one.
What?
No!
Why do you have multiple combinations of the same thing?
If you only have...
As every good scientist, he keeps the solution in his head.
I figured it out.
It's redacted, then redacted, after redacted, lastly
redacted.
Classified.
This square, this one square is classified.
Everything else.
Okay.
Maybe we can change, changing variables, maybe we switch
out...
Two and three?
Oh, oops, my bad.
Minto, it's redacted!
Please!
Okay, then I'll switch these two as well.
I was, I was, I don't remember why I was hitting escape for
something.
Yeah!
smarty pants oh is that not good the prism shattered oh
darling's prototypes have a lot of issues oh we need a new
plan oh speak with but oh did i do it wrong we need more
black rock prisms to make this machine work darling has
another lab down in the black rock processing site and
maintenance that must be where he keeps the prisms i've been
to maintenance already can find my way but how long will
that take nothing here is simple it's true i need to ask her
now before i go i need something from you first what do you
know about dylan faden i knew this was coming lives are at
stake here and we need this machine working to save those
lives once that is done director faden then we can talk oh
she's right as much as i don't want to admit Of course she
knows.
I'm the only one who can help.
I'll get the Prisms first.
Dylan, we'll have to wait just a little longer.
No, Dylan!
But don't call me, Director.
Jesse is fine.
I'll call you fate.
Here, you'll need this keycard.
Four?
Thanks.
Yippee!
Emily Pope has set up a base and executive.
Once I have the Prism, I'll meet you there.
Right.
I'll move out immediately.
and keep an eye out for darling finding him might be the key
to stopping the hiss it's just one large-scale HRA it's
there now we are about to be exposed to a different kind of
resonance hostile viral invasive resonance I think that's
That's what the headroom residence amplifiers are for.
Yeah Taking the protection headroom can provide us and
Keeping us from being wiped out
Whoa, this is all inside I'm sorry what
Complete mission for back to central research
Where here oh nice Thanks.
Much appreciated.
Okay, you guys stay safe.
Bye-bye.
Whoa.
Emergency supply storage.
This place is...
I mean, I know this place is big because it's like able
to...
Are we going to get ambushed in here?
Again.
Probably.
I want to go see that one lab.
black rock processing wait what is that right there oh those
are the guys those are the guys wait we might be okay
actually then um maintenance central maintenance where the
heck is central we're in central research why doesn't it
tell me where to go can I feel get a feel better beam I'm a
bit sick Mr. Factor feel better feel better beam
I think it's the elevator.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Oh
my gosh.
I can't pick it up.
I couldn't pick it up.
Ouch.
I'm going to die here.
Please.
Holy cow.
Okay, hold on.
Oh my gosh.
There's so many grenades.
Wow.
What the heck?
Okay.
This is the right way, alright?
Wow!
Okay, okay.
Reminder that you still have that side mission.
Yes, I know, to listen to the...
Oh!
No, it put me all the way out here.
Okay, we're still on the Black Rock processing, though.
Wait, do I still have...
Then I should still have the...
Oh, no.
Yeah, abilities.
Um, I said I was gonna do shield.
I guess maybe shield would be good for that.
Um...
I have four.
Oh, we could do four in the shield barrage.
What was it?
Shield rush, right?
When holding shield, use evade to rush at enemies and knock
them back.
Okay.
So we can...
That's the one that people have said is pretty good, right?
And we have seas.
More energy is good too, though, always.
Why is the last one only 15%?
Consumes quite a bit of energy, unfortunately.
I like using shield to get health pickups in the middle of
battle.
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna think about it because we can always you know we
can always oh I can finally get this construct pierce if we
want to try it um it is charged or should there's also this
construct spin but by the time I get the rest of the ritual
impulses I might have enough for it you know enough source
and everything so it'll eat it up let's get it
Okay, then load out.
We now have a shatter.
We'll do pierce on this guy.
Damage while low on health.
Damage after kills, headshot damage.
I guess I'll do damage while low on health.
I feel like these next guys kind of like...
Oh, oops.
This one.
Is this not it?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, wait.
I guess it's easier to get to the side quest from here now,
isn't it?
All that grenade tennis coming and going reminds me of your
half-life two run.
You're so right!
It was this lab, no.
Just kidding.
Oh, shoot.
Where was it?
Up here?
Did I go in here?
I don't think I did.
Oh my gosh, I missed a bathroom.
How could I?
I missed a bathroom to explore.
I feel like a dog sometimes where I'm like, I gotta sniff
every bathroom.
I gotta sniff every toilet.
And I also missed this shelter.
So backtracking.
Or maybe I didn't miss this shelter.
Oh, yes, I did.
Yay!
Yeah, okay.
What is this one?
I don't remember if I did it.
Oh, it's just this thing.
It like hits the horseshoe.
We are at level four, so I still can't go in here.
There's another one.
Oh, I like that one.
That's a nice sound.
I like that one.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, it's these things.
Gosh,
that's so over for me.
Leave me alone.
Oh, they're all gone.
Do you want to be my buddy?
Oh.
Never bud.
He hates me that much.
Oh, when did I switch back?
I forgot also we can change our...
Wait, where's our...
It won't let me change outfits.
It won't let me change!
Like, we're smelly in the same outfit.
Nice moves.
Thank you.
Did I have to go down the...
The hell of it?
Where is it going?
Maybe it would have been easier to just...
I can't remember at all where it was.
Changing outfits can only be done in Central Executive.
Oh, okay, okay.
We can always fast travel there.
Went to a great con this weekend.
Pleasure fun!
Where the heck was it?
Why am I so lost?
Wait, we can always do the tracking.
Hold on.
Oh, let's...
Take the tape back to the ritual office.
Huh?
I don't remember.
I feel like I'm doing...
I feel like I'm going crazy.
Where was- oh, it was down here!
It was down here!
No?
Right?
Wait.
It says I go- I go- I have to get into the thing.
Right?
I gotta get into the pod.
Oh, and the pod wasn't here.
This should be interesting.
Oh!
Welcome to my guided imagery experience.
Lesson one, Morito No.
Exercise one, the forest of positive interactions.
My name is Tokui Yoshimi Hakase.
My name is Dr. Yoshimi Tokui.
Trust my words.
Yeah, I'm here for you.
I'm here for you.
Okay.
Oh,
I'm playing.
The waves are rolling in and the seagulls are fighting over
a discarded bag of potato chips.
I believe they're jalapeno flavored.
The forest is in the ocean.
I see something in the middle of the ocean.
They appear to be trees.
Maybe I'm just trying to keep people away.
Maybe I'm just trying to understand.
Perhaps they are ocean trees.
Or perhaps they are metaphors for how you push people away.
Oh.
Let's find out together.
Just walk over the waves, friend.
The trees look lonely.
Why don't you talk to them?
Hello?
Moshi, Moshi.
Are you guys Japanese trees?
Moshi, sasai kakimashou.
You miss this part?
You whisper to the trees.
You tell them that they deserve love, that everyone deserves
love.
The trees agree.
They will now form healthy, respectful relationships with
other trees.
Or shrubs.
Whatever they prefer.
Now let's leave these trees to their love.
Go find it.
Do not let it darken our forest of emotions.
It's a forklift.
It is not the same thing.
It's a huge tire and a beach will arouse.
A forklift.
It does not like the tree's romance.
It is ruining our lovely beach with its hateful tires.
What?
Oh.
It ran over one of the gulls.
Oh my God!
Turn off the machine.
Oh my god!
The box is so sad!
The potato chips were for his pregnant wife.
The forklift must be stopped.
Oh my god!
Oh.
I can stop them!
You.
Yeah.
The bird was pregnant and wanted jalapeno chips.
The murderous machine will kill no more.
It's a forklift.
That doesn't really do that, but...
The trees and love are undisturbed.
Hawklift, ...
...
Your mind is a safe haven for love.
Doesn't that feel nice?
Aren't you feeling healthier?
Oh my, it seems we're all out of time.
Stay receptive, friend.
Wow!
That actually was relaxing.
That was nice.
Strangely insightful.
So wait, is there another tape that we have to get?
Oh, the one in the ritual division.
Well, shoot!
I liked this one, though.
Life changing.
Um, what do I get out of this?
I mean, I guess we'll Oh, man.
It's always these things, too.
I don't like them.
So I want to leave.
I'm just leaving, to be honest.
Because I don't like them.
I don't like them.
Oh, oops.
That's not what I meant to press.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that's not what I meant to press.
Please.
Can I close it?
There we go.
Yeah, they know.
I knew I was relaxed.
Are they even here?
I can't tell.
I'm just gonna leave.
And ignore them.
And we can go somewhere else, baby.
So...
Okay.
They're like still screaming over there?
The voice...
Ah!
How did that happen?
So much for closing the door.
Right!
It came in from this way!
There's no way!
The voiceover was Kojima.
I thought so, but I was just like...
That would be so funny.
funny okay um we are going to shoot okay hold on we are
currently at the astral exhibition oh my god this place is
ginormous it said we needed to go to hold on let's go back
to our missions Marshall sends Jesse to black rock
processing in the maintenance sector to retrieve more black
rock prisms she promises to tell Jesse what she knows about
Dylan once they The HRA production is up and running again.
Whoa, we have more Raiders today?
Holy cow, so many.
Thank you so much.
Welcome, welcome.
Oh, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Okay, hold on.
So research maintenance.
Where is, is it this right here?
This looks like it's probably it, right?
so if we go to but there's also well there's also like down
here and pipes and stuff and there's also all through oh
wait there's all through here as well if i were oh this
place is so big oh my gosh okay you can get the other tapes
how many are there that's not my name as far as um oh i
guess i could have whoops uh find the tape taken to the
ritual office
The control room is a good place to TP for that.
I was thinking that too.
Okay.
We have a new one?
You?
Launch.
I want to keep...
Health is good, but I want to keep the launch energy cost
low too.
So...
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Pop into Central.
That's true.
Let's just go to that.
Let's just go to Central.
right so we can change our outfit we're we're two and a half
hours into the stream and i forgot to change my outfit but
it's fine um then we can probably grab the other tape and go
back and do the other relaxing part i think
An outfit.
So we did this one before.
Urban response.
It's not...
Wait, it's the same outfit but red.
Uh.
Oh.
Oh, man.
Well, she's got the cool...
She's got the cool control shirt on.
So we'll do that.
Let's go see how Emily is doing anyway.
Hi!
Wait, what is this?
Linguistic ability?
Oh wait, this is Emily's research, no?
Yeah, compiled by Emily Pope.
Researchers were sent to transcribe the recursive chant
repeated by the Hiss entities.
In the interest of safety, this was done with the
non-aggressive floating Hiss entities.
However, no distinction between this repeating phrase and
the one repeated by the more violent hiss entities has been
observed.
What is the purpose of this repeating string of words?
And is this how the hiss corrupts individuals?
Does the chant produce a physical effect?
Is it a message in incantation?
We were able to record a first-hand recitation of the
chanting.
See the corresponding audio record.
So sorry.
In a game where you should be...
Where there's so much reading.
My talking is...
not so great today hi Jesse hi Jesse it's me um darling's
whereabouts I keep finding traces of darling but still can't
find him yeah where could he be but he's usually in his
office in research or one of his labs dr. darling has quite
a few all around the Bureau mm-hmm could be hiding in any
one of them I check myself but I don't have access to most
of them Sounds like I touched a nerve.
He didn't let you into his laps?
Not all of them, no.
Some had volatile material.
This is ridiculous.
I mean, this whole place is volatile material.
Could have at least thought up a more convincing lie.
How can I work without access to all the data possible?
Hmm.
Her answer is have you tried looking harder?
Actually, though.
See you soon.
Be careful out there.
You know, I just realized that the mission does say central
maintenance.
And that's where I think we were looking at.
It's ridiculous.
Uh.
Or I guess I was looking at the power plant.
But the control room is probably...
Wait.
Or the power plant maybe.
The power plant is probably the best.
Well, we can go to the control room.
And we can...
how do i get to here it could be a it could be a door that i
couldn't open before there's also all of this but the
furnace chambers these ones were high up they were in the
fans i remember that
the main elevator is the closest is it i think i remember
you guys telling me the map in this This is so confusing.
It's so confusing.
It's so hard to follow.
Where are we headed?
Maintenance sector.
Take me home.
Country roads.
I thank you guys for helping me with this.
I'm glad the map is notoriously bad.
Everybody knows it to be bad, so you guys don't mind helping
me so much.
Oh.
Marshall knows something about Dylan.
Yes.
Is he here?
Is he all right?
HRAs first.
They'll help save everyone including Dylan once I find him.
Can you keep him safe?
Like you do with me?
You keep me safe?
Because...
No.
How have I been in here before?
Yes.
I remember I got ambushed in here!
I should have converted that guy huh you should have been my
friend wait was that a no oh there's a thing to heal them
wait I'm
reloading one second ambush me one shame on me ambush me
twice shame on you
That I could not go to.
Oh, hello.
Oh.
You are my friend.
Yeah, take him out.
Uh, and then you will explode.
I think.
Afterwards.
Isn't that correct?
Ew, look at him.
Ew.
Explode.
Whoa, whoa.
Wallalo!
Yes, exactly!
And I remember there was something over here as well.
I forgot about the tape, but that's okay.
Uh, there was something weird in this room.
Yeah, we couldn't make it across.
Where am I looking at?
I see.
I'm- the chat is kind of blocking it a little bit, but it's
at the very top.
You can see my red dot.
See it moving?
Yeah.
But this is...
This is processing, so this is where we need to go.
Oh, I like the effect.
Do you guys kind of see, like, the...
I don't know if it's just...
Yeah, you can see, like, it light up a little bit.
Those enemies are probably going to respawn.
You're so right.
I'm not...
I want to go through door four.
You're so right, they're probably going to respawn.
Because I went in here.
Maybe?
The light tearing?
Yeah, but it looks like an effect.
It looks pretty cool.
I like it.
No, I have it.
Oh, wow.
Let's not try to kill me.
Right?
Okay, what's down here?
He still has his job board missions too.
Oh, that's right.
Yeah.
Oh, this is just if we fall down.
Good to know.
But that won't happen, right guys?
No, it won't.
You're too good.
No.
You're the parkour queen.
First time.
What if I put it in that one?
What starts up?
okay
ambush no
where are we going
but then there's two things here right I'm like powering
something up but I'm not quite sure what wait I wonder if
it's like am I powering the walkway who knows I don't know
There was another one.
Uh.
Where did it go?
Is it the one down there?
Where do you go?
You.
No!
Okay.
I guess we will find that eventually, right?
Have fun with it.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Whoa.
Notice.
Ocean View Motel and Casino Entry Point!
The law of three applies.
Cool!
Wait!
Hold on.
I'm not quite ready to do that yet.
It is really bright.
Is there a ladder if I fall?
Wait, this is the area that we came from.
Okay, never mind.
Like, that's the security point room.
It just drops down into it.
Alright, here we go.
A one.
A two.
A three.
Traverse the motel.
Hello?
Wait, I hear someone talking.
The notoriously loud music.
Somebody was actually here that's so funny.
Yeah, no vacancy, buddy.
Rule of one.
Rule of two.
Rule of three.
You can't even hear the bell over how loud it is.
Still nothing here.
All right.
Wait, okay, wait.
What is it to solve here?
Oh, wait.
It's the same thing again.
I forgot.
I forgot you ring the bell and it opens these.
This one's open, too.
Oh.
Fixed.
Wait.
Oh, is it like one of those...
The chair needs to be out, maybe?
Maybe.
Oh, something opened, I think.
Yeah.
I got it.
Yeah, I spot the difference.
I wonder, though, did the other doors open?
Because...
That one's closed.
Yeah, only the ones on the left open.
Okay.
It's so loud.
Holy cow.
Okay.
A one.
A two.
A three.
Yay!
Continue towards black rock processing.
Whoa.
Okay.
The lights off even.
Um, I guess we could go back through here, right?
Nice!
That wasn't so bad, right?
Ouch.
Beep, beep.
Let me through, let me through.
Let me in, let me in.
All right.
Okay, we need to find a way to block rock.
processing that's where marshall said we'd find a prism
there's a lot highlighted here atlas theory the atlas is a
physical expression created by the oldest house its purpose
and function are currently unknown the specific shape and
dimensions of the atlas see file atl03 for said dimension
seem to indicate more explicit purpose than the oldest
house's usual walls floors and shifts the atlas changes form
but resists observation when doing oh it's one of those no
visual visual observation has been made during its change it
only ever occurs between frames when monitored by
surveillance cameras a previous theory was that this change
corresponds to house shifts and that the atlas is a redacted
of the redacted itself however the shape changes do not
occur at the same time as the building shifts which makes
this theory doubtful structurally the atlas is made of the
same the rest of the oldest house.
Further observation will hopefully aid in discovering its
purpose.
I see.
Quantum.
Wait.
What is the oldest house made of?
It's kind of crazy.
Like the architecture.
Isn't this architecture type have like a name?
It's like brutalist architecture or something, right?
Or it's very like...
I don't know.
I don't even, how do you describe it?
No, we need clearance five.
Brutalist, yeah, yeah.
It's so...
If you like this style, I'm sure you could look up Brutalist
architecture, you'll be a fan, maybe.
Harsh and imposing.
Yeah.
Oh.
Okay.
Aha.
Oh.
Oh, F.
Oh, I thought it was a...
I thought it was something else.
Okay, cool.
I'm not artistic enough to understand architecture.
That's okay.
Look alive.
Oh.
Something's going on.
Oh, something's going on.
Okay, let's go help out.
We've got this.
Nice.
There's another guy?
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
You're my friend.
Woolalo!
Yeah.
Where are they?
Where are you?
Got him.
Oh my gosh, there's more of them.
Woolalo!
mind.
What just happened?
Holy cow.
Wait, can I not wallolo you?
Oh my god, I can't see anything.
My friend.
Suppress him!
Oh, oops.
Sorry, I was trying to get him.
You okay?
Your friend.
Are we good?
I don't even know how to get up there.
Oh, there's a staircase right there.
They're just sleeping.
Where?
I don't even see- Ow!
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Quit it!
Everybody okay down here?
I'm sure we're fine.
Great!
Everybody okay in here?
Where did they all go?
Up where?
Under where?
Hey,
you made it!
You made it!
He's like sitting there they're traumatized he's like oh my
god all my friends are dead they want to go out sometime is
there anything over on that side
nice fight director thank you one one survivor again one but
a good one my favorite motto
one but a good one Alright, thank you.
This is what I'm looking for.
Threshold remnant.
Oh, what are we watching?
During an AWE investigation, our agents discovered a light
switch cord in a Butte bungalow closet.
Fredthum is direct impacted by an anti-tank rocket.
Oof, ouch, owey.
Oof.
like hey inside they found a door marked with an inverted
black pyramid yes i went just like that it led back to the
oldest house yes i went thousand miles from montana crazy
now we're finding the cord and increasing numbers throughout
the bureau somehow the two places they became in tune to
each other the the actual physical location of the ocean
view is is a mystery He's stepping beyond his walls has so
far proven impossible.
Dr. Darling.
He's a power.
Like the oldest house.
Reminds me of like the guy from fairly odd parents if he,
you know, if he like harnessed his power.
Brutalism.
Raw exposed concrete.
That's just where the name originated.
It can be used up.
It can use other materials.
Warmth color.
Oh, neat.
I didn't know that.
I only knew it like being like super concrete-y.
I want to see other types then.
Shelter!
Yeah, Mr. Crocker!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Fairies!
Kind of feel bad going into the shelters and taking their
supplies.
because it's a oh oh hi you're still you i am i i left one
of your men down there oh you're okay we'll push through
this the hiss of the ones doing the push in dark oh no
wait do they all do all their things like glow like that it
looks cool man you okay too much happy juice too much happy
juice you were the director they are your your supplies oh
so they're like pickmen we need to get them to a surgical
station ASAP but I don't think they're still they're like my
supplies my soldiers are dispensable like little pickmans
have you noticed the recent tension between trench and
darling they've both been acting odd lately oh my gosh
they're just they're they're making they're typing the tea
in like and they're signing it with the official federal
bureau of control stamps they're sealing the tea they're
like gossiping and like passing it off as as like official
mail yeah the drama have you noticed the recent tension
between trench and darling they've both been acting odd
lately right like trench concerns me the most.
His sudden hostility towards Darling's project is very
unlike him.
He was the one to approve of this hadron research in the
first place, but after Darling unveiled those extra rays, he
was livid.
I personally don't see any reason not to equip Biro staff
with an additional protective device, especially not if it's
as strong as Darling says.
Like, what do you make of this?
either of them strikes you odd let's talk in person soon
before the next bureau heads meeting um wait oh it's
Marshall oh my gosh wait it says Marshall trench oh my god
you guys they're acting like so freaky okay everybody's sad
and tired I'm here to help I got you thanks for bringing
down that whatever the fuck that was I don't know, your
guess is good as mine.
Official documentation.
Director Minky is like, you know.
I tell him.
The truth is harsh, but these people seem familiar with
death.
The hiss are everywhere.
Yeah.
Most of the Bureau is lost.
We need Black Rock Prism to make more HRAs for any survivors
in the safe rooms.
I'm here to check Darling's Black Rock Lab.
So to recap, death, disaster, and imminent destruction.
Yep.
Another day at the FBC.
past black rock processing oh i got good well one of them
right on that front what good news is it's right down the
hall yay bad news is a hiss monster has decided to move in
so that's great monster monster that's what the rangers said
the ones that survived anyway but we are just treading water
here and the hiss keep coming they do it's like never ending
security team into the containment sector just before the
lockdown happened and well no one's seen him since oh hey at
least we got you our fearless leader they shouldn't rely on
me they don't know me why would anyone work here they don't
know how I failed people well someone's gotta do it right or
else the world will be in chaos if all these paranormal
items were everywhere doing whatever the heck they want I'm
getting kind of used to them alright be sure to put a bullet
in that thing for me okay
Find a black rock prism.
Oh, they opened the door for me.
Thank you very much.
Hmm.
Sounds wet here, but nothing looks wet.
I missed it.
Who's fading?
Us.
We are fading.
Jesse fading.
Oh, no, my buddy.
Oh, little Pikmin.
No.
oh another oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh Arish wasn't kidding about that monster oh oh
I wish there was a save point did we see a monster in here
there's some dudes floating You missed a recording in the
room with a reiss?
Oh, thank you.
I will go back.
Oh, this is the door.
I'm just...
I'm stomping on their bodies.
Let's put it in here.
Oh, there was this.
Oh, no, I saw that door.
A recording.
Recording.
Ah, thank you.
Ranger Squad, Charlie 7, returned from an expedition into
the quarry threshold just after 0500 Zulu.
Can you please state your names and describe the purpose of
your expedition?
Kevin Horowitz.
Rupert Weldon.
Our mission was to map Cori grid coordinates G29.
This is a Black Rock Cori.
The objective, as always, was to find a route from the
threshold entrance and maintenance to the formation.
Secondary objective was not a success.
What is it, Brad?
That shit that doesn't...
Shut up!
I've seen Parapsychosis, but what the hell is a worm through
time?
No, nothing.
Do you think we should talk about the...
mermaid yeah the mermaid how are what's here found this
mermaid in the quarry just sitting on some black who la la
oh siren oh I'd say she was more enchanting than the
learning fine enchanting did you tell you about this no
because it didn't happen huh nothing happened oh as usual
the quarry is full of rock That's it.
Can we go now?
Fuck you guys.
Yeah!
Get out of here.
Get my hopes up.
That guy was really excited about it.
He was like, A mermaid you say?
Where?
What does she look like?
What did you ask for her number?
I'm scared to go in here.
We don't have five.
Okay.
Um...
Is this where the said monster is going to be?
I'm a little nervous.
I'm a little nervous over said monster.
Did she say anything about me?
Is she single?
Oh...
BlackRock Lab.
BlackRock Processing.
Here we go.
You showed me the HRA when I first got here.
And the machine that makes them.
Can you help me find a prism?
Here?
I'm going to explore real quick before we do that.
Everybody's so noisy in this game, huh?
Gosh, can't have a moment's rest.
No wonder they're like, get them to stop talking.
Okay, there's an explosive here.
explodey bit explodey bit maybe if I like pick up the whole
thing you know I could throw over the explodey
whoa sorry I didn't mean to get so close I didn't mean to
make you uncomfortable okay there's like nothing here okay
cool I'm nervous okay let's try this
can we grab it With our bare hands?
They're shattered.
What the fuck?
Uh.
Oh.
Where'd it go?
Where'd that thing go?
Hello?
Woo!
Okay.
Ew!
Is that it right there?
She's so alluring, you guys.
Oh, there's more?
Or...
That was it dying.
Okay.
Not missions.
Collectibles?
His disorder...
Disorder...
Distorted.
His distorted agents are able to render themselves invisible
and emit a powerful concussive blast when in close range.
Luckily, I didn't have to experience that.
Oh, no!
Curiously, the hiss distorted is apparently not able to
utilize both abilities at once.
It must make itself visible when it goes on the offensive.
Okay.
I don't like it, though.
I have some things I've missed, it seems.
Objects of power are holders To the other Behold the reins,
law We are failing in translating hyperreal concepts Secrets
instructions will be lost Ignore this message Ignore it
Never mind We didn't watch that Oh unread Oh All the Tokui
tapes!
Yeah, we still gotta do that.
And all of these.
The darling presentations.
Okay.
Wait, where is he talking from?
I hear him.
I'll hear there.
We call these areas thresholds.
The quarry is one of the more stable thresholds in the
maintenance sector.
That's where black rock comes from you heard that too right
black rock comes from oh yes hold are you so the prisms must
be there too think of it as perinatural lead our research
involves many dangerous things we absolutely need to keep in
check that's what the black rock line firebreaks are about
the penopticon container cells sorry to interrupt sir but i
need the code for the bio later Oh, uh, Emily.
The codes.
BlackRock 665.
Uh, 665.
He did say that.
Neighbor of the Beast.
Ah!
Get it?
She's a hater.
Neighbor of the Beast?
The, the, wait, the hotline said 665 also, though.
Wait, that's kind of crazy, no?
Oh, this should get us into the quarry.
Oh, shoot.
Wow!
Black Rock has allowed the Bureau to make great strides in
containment procedures since it was first discovered.
This report will examine how its very structure is comprised
of redacted density that nullifies all resonances with a
range of redacted to redacted hertz.
So like you said, it's perinatural lead, so it like stops
all the- wow.
So is that what like this whole place is built out of
basically?
Well I guess it couldn't be because- I mean not built
entirely.
Unless like that's how stuff doesn't escape.
right bureau innovations that incorporate black rock will be
analyzed most notably the fire breaks feats of engineering
designed to contain any future outbreaks attacks or any
other internal threats yeah it keeps the spooky from getting
out exactly it's the black stuff you see on the doors that
makes oh my gosh the mines the goal of this report is to
encourage bureau staff to explore further innovations using
black rock as work in that field has markedly slowed in
recent They kind of were like, oh, we've got the stuff.
We don't need to know anymore, right?
It works.
It works as intended.
I came from there.
What is up here?
Items.
There's a guy right there.
What did I get?
Ritual impulse, nice.
Ooh.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah, they're so creepy.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
The house itself is an object of power, if I recall.
I mean, that would make sense, right?
The oldest house keeps it in, but it must have doors, and
doors are weakness.
That's why they use the black rock for doors.
Yeah, okay, it makes sense.
Are you just hanging around?
Isn't that so funny?
I've never heard that joke before.
So, black rock door.
Black rock door.
We're going.
Everything here is crazy.
It is.
It's weird, but it feels right.
Right.
Like how the world should be.
I am in an infinite building leading to different dimensions
and I never want to leave.
Jesse?
Even with all the horror, I'm...
Happy.
I'm sane.
Or just the right kind of...
Oh, shoot.
Alrighty.
Whoa.
Holy cow.
Who else wants to mess with a mega?
Oh, you guys.
Oh, shoot.
My friend.
My friend, you are my friend, you are my friend, you are my
friend, you are my friend, you are my friend.
Whoa, whoa!
Oh.
How do you look, friend?
Ooh.
You've seen better days.
We'll let him run out.
See ya.
You felt it too, Minto.
I'm feeling...
I'm dead, but I feel alive in this place.
black rock quarry and this is control room
I'll take that launch up yay yay we had a save point oh it's
been a while since we've had one so nice nice nice nice well
guys I think I'll end it here then this might be a good spot
to quit because I think it's going to be a lot of
exploration after this, perhaps.
It won't be...
I'll just pick it up in a couple days from now, so it won't
be like a week from now at all.
Yeah, the map certainly feels that way.
Where are we?
We're not even...
Oh, we have looked at...
Okay, we've unlocked the part on the right, which is nice.
okay we're back here
but that whole area on the left is humongous and redacted so
next stream mint will be talking about how crazy the map
actually feels right see you next time doctor darling I
would have I would have beat that guy so bad doctor darling
come on but this is this is been really fun thank you guys
for the help with uh figuring out the map i don't know what
i would be so lost without you guys oh janitor's office wait
a second have we been here before thanks for the stream
director glad you're having fun hope you have a yummy dinner
tonight i will i will i will i have i have skitty on the
menu let's go yeah
I think I remember.
Wait, I remember this room.
I remember where we are.
Oh, oh, this place is crazy, but it's...
Oh, look.
Thank you guys so much, Spaghetti-chan.
Who's that?
It's all interconnected.
Yeah.
I guess it makes it... I guess it once you start unlocking
doors, like, because, you know, obviously I couldn't unlock
this one before.
Oh, I guess it gets easier.
You know, I don't even think I noticed.
I don't think I even processed, like, the Black Rock Quarry
or anything before.
So, I'm excited to keep going!
Yeah!
Thanks to the stream, Winto.
Thank you for watching!
Thank you, thank you!
Um, I want to say something real quick before we, before I
head out.
I'm working on my schedule for upcoming week, but I will be
having a Off collab this week
Off collab, off collab So You can look forward to that You
can look forward to that You can look forward to that So
yeah, I have a friend coming over for a couple days yes with
Johnny I won't say who even though some of you may have
already guessed or someone may have already said but I'm
gonna keep it mysterious I'm gonna keep it mysterious she
already tweeted oh my god I can't have anything well don't
read chat and now it's time for my cats to eat again see you
next time enjoy your collab with whoever she told us no
thank you me to love the control streams and and the rest
thank you thank you thank you thank you so much have a great
day silly and i hope you also have a great day great night
great time zone and i will haunt you next time Ikta nasha!
Whoa!
Sarcasmic, thank you!
Pretty sure I forgot to introduce myself in the motion, you
meet and greet, but thank you for complimenting my men
cosplay.
Yes!
Thank you!
Thank you for cosplaying me, twin.
Thank you, thank you!
Oachamito, everybody!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!
Fake me, thank you!
Bye-bye!